wir haben einen der wichtigsten
deutschen denker eingeladen um darüber
zu reden wie die korona krise unser
leben verändert was bedeutet es denn
wenn eine umarmung plötzlich zur gefahr
wird kann man freiheit gegen gesundheit
abwägen und wird sich unsere
gesellschaft auf dauer durch diese krise
verändern
herzlich willkommen richard david precht
hallo herr ist ja ja fangen wir doch
gleich mit der interessantesten frage an
wird sich unser leben auf dauer
verändern oder kehren wir nach der krise
wenn sie denn jemals vorbei sein sollte
wieder zum zustand bevor zurück ich
glaube dass hier sehr weitgehend zum
zustand davor zurück kehren also die
menschen werden sich sehr gerne wieder
daran gewöhnen sich zu umarmen den
öffentlichen nahverkehr zu benutzen und
ohne masken rumzulaufen also ich denke
dass die alltags rituale anbelangt so
glaube ich nicht dass die korona krise
eine langfristige auswirkungen haben
wird sondern die leute werden froh sein
diesbezüglich zu ihrem alten leben
zurückzukehren
es gibt ja einige menschen die auch sehr
große hoffnungen in die veränderung
wirkung dieser krise setzen zum beispiel
viele leute die sagen naja
konsumverzicht ist er vielleicht ganz
schön wenn die leute merken dass wir
vieles gar nicht brauchen ja also
gefühlsmäßig kann man das erstmal
nachvollziehen
also diese entschleunigte zeit die
korona zeit gerade im frühjahr für viele
dargestellt hat diese endlose abfolge
von sonnentagen wurde ja von vielen
leuten nicht nur als gespenstisch
wahrgenommen sondern zum teil auch
irgendwie als beruhigend sie erinnerte
mich persönlich oft an meine kindheit in
den 60er 70er jahren so wenig
straßenverkehr dieser flugzeug lose
himmel und dass man dann darüber
nachdenkt und fragt muss dieses leben
des schneller höher weiter was ihr ein
unglaublich hartes diktat unseres lebens
ist und immer mehr konsum und mehr
verkehr und mehr reisen und so muss das
eigentlich sein und ich glaube diese
erfahrung haben viele gemacht
darüber wollen wir uns nachher
ausführlich unterhalten ich würde
trotzdem zunächst mal ein paar worte
gerne verlieren über die situation in
der wir jetzt gerade sinnvoll an
mit der demonstration am vergangenen
samstag gegen die korona maßnahmen wie
schätzen sie das ein also ich würde als
erstes mal sagen es gibt immer einen
gewissen prozentsatz von leuten die
jeder mainstream meinung grundsätzlich
misstrauen die auch das ball corona ton
und die das mit ihren eigenen fantasien
aufladen was auch immer das ist so und
das ist grundsätzlich in ordnung weil
wir leben in einem freien land
ja und jeder der irgendeine meinung hat
darf die auch vertreten
die frage ist nur wo ist der punkt
erreicht wo bestimmte dinge eintreten
die nicht mehr gehen so und als
staatsbürger wenig gezogen in solchen
versammlungen der maske zu tragen also
muss ich das auch tun
es ist meine persönliche entscheidung
darüber zu befinden ob ich das richtig
finde oder nicht ist ja nicht meine
persönliche entscheidung darüber zu
befinden ob ich rote ampeln als vorbote
akzeptiere oder nicht ja und wenn ich
dagegen verstoßen muss ich damit rechnen
dass ich dafür auch eine strafe krieg
was anderes ist dass nazis diese
veranstaltung gekapert haben für ihre
zwecke
das würde ich aber jetzt mal von der
korona demo als solcher auch ein
bisschen unterscheiden
also haben sie verständnis für leute die
da mitlaufen mit demonstrieren weil sie
sich an diesen maßnahmen stören und dann
nicht so darauf achten wer da alles mit
live verschwörungstheoretiker neonazis
verständnis aber ich sage es ist erlaubt
verständnis habe ich ehrlich gesagt
nicht also wenn man wenn man wirklich
glaubt das wichtigste thema wäre jetzt
sich irgendwo da rein zu fräsen und zu
vermuten dass der start irgendwelche
diktatorischen absichten hat und dass
bill gates irgendwelche wahnsinnig
finsteren absichten hatte um noch
unendlich viel reicher zu werden und so
dieser ganzen blödsinn
dafür habe ich kein verständnis aber
nach wie vor einem freien land dürfen
die leute alles mögliche denken solange
sie nicht leib und leben anderer
gefährden oder so eine hetzpropaganda
wie die nazis vorgehen ist dann diese
demonstration sowie sie abliefen eine
gefahr für die demokratie oder erden
ausweis dafür dass bei uns ja die
demokratie funktioniert das ist eine
ziemlich große frage weil man muss ja
auf der einen seite die die museen und
auf der anderen seite der sie was da vor
dem reichstag passiert ist das war eine
kleine gewaltbereite minderheit die sich
überlegt hat diesem sturm auf den
reichstag anzutreten und das sehe ich
eigentlich grundsätzlich hat zwei
verschiedene dinge nicht wahr
eine gruppe hat eine andere demo
sozusagen für ihre zwecke gebrauchen
dass man solche demos zulässt so lange
die leute eine maske tragen und sich an
ihre pflichten halten sehe ich in anti
corona demo es jetzt keinen anschlag auf
die demokratie oder sowas
im prinzip ist es ja auch eine ungeheuer
schwierige frage abzuwägen hier
freiheitsrechte und da das recht auf
gesundheit und leben
wie kann man wie alle aber vor allem die
regierung die ja diese maßnahmen
beschließen muss denn das sinnvoll
abwägen und nicht nur aus dem bauch
heraus
also es wäre ja schön wenn wir so eine
art rechenmaschine hätten wo wir genau
sagen können so und so viel freiheit und
so viel gesundheit und alle
philosophischen modelle für der
philosophische utilitarismus gesagt wir
müssen wir das leiden auf der einen
seite und das glück auf der anderen
seite fortwährend miteinander abwägen
die funktionieren eben nicht weil das
reale leben ist keine rechenaufgabe
das hat alles so viel folgen die man
nicht übersehen und deswegen haben wir
eigentlich gar keine andere wahl als
situativ aus dem bauch heraus zu
entscheiden und wir haben das glück in
einem föderalen system zu leben wo man
angemessen handeln kann als täter um
angemessenheit das geht nicht um
grundsätzliches gut und richtig im
absoluten sinne sondern es geht darum
angemessen proportionen einzuschätzen
und das geht natürlich in einem
föderalen system wie wir das haben sehr
gut und ich verstehe auch dass sich die
situation in sachsen anhalt oder
mecklenburg vorpommern anders darstellt
als in nordrhein westfalen oder in
bayern
es gibt ja leute die abwägung ist
relativ einfach weil das recht auf leben
und gesundheit steht über allen anderen
rechten kann man das ein versagt so
nicht in unserer verfassung also der
wichtigste verfassungsgrundsatz ist
nicht die gesundheit des menschen ist
unantastbar so nah die würde des
menschen des 100 tastbaren da wird ein
bisschen mehr zu wald seine gesundheit
es ist ja interessant dass in dieser
pandemie gerade die politiker am besten
ankommt die höchsten zustimmungswerte
bekommen die für besonders drastische
maßnahmen eintreten vor allem angela
merkel und der bayerische
ministerpräsident am wochenende
ich würde sagen ich weiß nicht mehr so
ganz sicher ob das noch so ist nun das
war zumindest in den ersten monaten so
und ich glaube das liegt einfach daran
wenn menschen sich unmittelbar an leib
und leben bedroht sind dann haben
die eine eine große zuneigung zu
verboten also haben einmal den schönen
satz geäußert die menschen lieben verbot
genau wenn es wenn es das muss man
natürlich dazu sagen
sie lieben dich verbote in tausend
kleinigkeiten sondern wenn es um ihre
elementaren lebens und
sicherheitsinteressen geht und zwar aus
dem einfachen grund weil die verbote
ihnen dann etwas abnehmen und ihnen
sicherheit geben die sich nicht selber
herstellen müssen also sie freuen sich
über einen funktionierenden staat in der
dafür sorgt dass ihre gesundheit
weitestgehend erhalten bleiben kann
und die finden reglementierung und
regeln die der staat an das genau wie im
straßenverkehr richtig
können sie das mal näher erläutern also
welches verbot finden die menschen jetzt
in dieser corona krise gut also ich
glaube dass die mehrheit aller menschen
die masken pflicht in geschäften oder
innerhalb von räumen für richtig hält
also ich sehe sehr wenig menschen die
dagegen verstoßen wir fallen dann immer
ganz besonders auf aber die meisten
leute glaube ich halte das für sehr
richtig dass keine massenveranstaltung
jetzt stattfinden halten auch die
meisten leute in diesem land für richtig
was bedeutet denn diese krise für sie
persönlich das was es sicher auch für
viele andere ist eine starke
entschleunigung meines lebens ich bin ja
mit sehr viel vorträgen normalerweise
unterwegs das sind jetzt sehr weniger
geworden und ich habe deutlich mehr zeit
in meinen büchern zu arbeiten und ich
habe auch mehr zeit für meine partnerin
ich hatte zwischendurch mehr zeit für
meinen sohn und auch mehr zeit für gute
freunde
das klingt jetzt alles sehr positiv ja
gut auf der anderen seite hat man
weniger geld verdient aber wenn man
dadurch nicht existenziell gefährdet ist
dann kann man mit den zugewinnen sehr
schätzen was haben sie dir dann meisten
vermisst in dieser krise das habe ich am
meisten vermisst ich weiß gar nicht ob
ich wirklich etwas elementar vermisst
habe so in der in der unmittelbaren
anfangszeit also das total locker und wo
man sich überlegen musste ob man jetzt
am rhein spazieren geht oder nicht
vollziehen geht da hatte ich am anfang
etwas bewegungsmangel
aber das ist dann sehr schnell in die
andere richtung ungeschlagen das man
eigentlich viel mehr fort gemacht
ansonsten gemacht hat also so wie sie
das jetzt die auswirkungen auf sie
persönlich schildern klingt das ja alles
sehr positiv entschleunigung und mehr
zeit für die lieder der voraussetzung
dass man auch sagen muss dass ich keine
angehörigen hatte die einen corona
schwer erkrankt waren oder daran
gestorben
auch wenn das jetzt so positiv bei ihm
klingt ich würde trotzdem gerne mal in
die zukunft gerichtete fragen es kann ja
sein dass wir in drei monaten im stoff
haben aber vielleicht haben wir ja auch
in drei jahren noch keinen impfstoff
also muss man sich ja darauf einrichten
dass wir mit diesem virus noch
vielleicht viele jahre leben hätten eine
gesellschaft halten wir das durch mit
den maßnahmen mit den beschränkungen die
gerade in kraft sind im zweifelsfall
noch auf jahre ein nein also es ist
völlig klar dass er wenn es einen
weiteren lockdown geben sollte wird er
nicht mehr ganz so drastisch sein wie
beim erstmaligen sparen hat das
angekündigte ich habe das schon vor
allen dingen woche in einem interview
mit dem handelsblatt gesagt es gibt
dinge die wird man nicht noch mal so
machen
man wird nicht den einzelhandel wieder
so komplett lahmlegen wie man das am
anfang gemacht hat man wird bei dem
bleiben was man im augenblick tut dass
man sagt im laden masken pflicht und
nicht zu viele leute in den laden
man wird keine öffentlichen parks
schließen das hat man ganz am anfang war
gemacht
also es gibt sicher einige maßnahmen die
man beim nächsten mal nicht macht und
wenn du dann dritter oder vierter
notwendig sein wird wird er sich immer
weiter abschwächen und sie sollte uns
corona tatsächlich so lange erhalten
bleiben was ich jetzt nicht für so
wahrscheinlich halte aber gesetze im
fall das ist so dann werden die leute
sich irgendwann ancona gewinnen das wird
dann irgendwann passieren weil man
dauerhaft eben diesen wirtschaftlichen
schaden nicht in kauf nehmen wird es
widerstrebt jedem jahr wahrscheinlich
irgendwie leben gegen freiheitsrechte
abzuwägen aber letztendlich muss man sie
am ende machen wenn man wenn man regeln
erlässt insofern spielt natürlich eine
rolle wie viel menschen sterben
eigentlich an corona und im moment haben
wir eine situation dass nicht mehr wie
im februar märz oder april da mehrere
hundert menschen am tag sterben sondern
fünf oder zehn in deutschland kommt muss
man dann zu einer anderen abwägung
kommen das sterben weniger also kann ich
auch nicht so viel
freiheitsrechte einschränken wie in der
situation wenn mehr leute sterben die
alles entscheidende frage wird sein den
grund herauszufinden warum er im
augenblick relativ wenig menschen schwer
an corona erkranken oder sterben
und da stehen ja verschiedene
erklärungsmodelle gegenwärtig im raum
die virologen mit denen ich gesprochen
habe sagen
es läge daran dass vor allem jüngere
infiziert sind das hat eine
eingeschränkte glaubwürdigkeit ich
erinnere daran dass von den vielen
tönnies mitarbeiter an der zahl weit
über 1000 an die 2000 die ancona
erkrankt ist soweit wir wissen kein
einziger schwer erkrankt ist oder
gestorben ist das waren zum größten teil
jetzt eben nicht ganz junge menschen und
erzähle ich die die aus dem urlaub
zurückgekehrt sind
es ist durchaus möglich dass das virus
sich abschwächte biologen können das
nicht beweisen so lange sie das nicht
beweisen können werden sie das in der
öffentlichkeit auch nicht sagen aber so
wie das auch unter virologen verbreitet
sein wird sich zu der meinung
durchzuringen oder die bestätigt zu
sehen dass das virus schwächer wird wird
die entscheidende zahl die ja überhaupt
die einzige entscheidende zahlen
natürlich nicht die zahl der infektionen
sein sondern die wirklich entscheidende
zahl ist die zahl der schweren
erkrankungen und ich bin sehr gespannt
wie das in den nächsten wochen weiter
analysiert wird wenn wir tatsächlich
eine mehrheit von biologen haben die der
überzeugung sind dass das virus sich
abschwächt dann werden wir die maßnahmen
die wir gegenwärtig ergriffen haben
nicht aufrechterhalten
sollte sich diese hypothese nicht
bewahrheiten werden wir sie aufrecht an
also wir haben ja längst nicht mehr
einen lock down in diesem drastischen
ausmaß wie das im märz und april war
trotzdem es gibt ja nach wie vor viele
einschränkungen das trifft glaube ich an
einer stelle zumindest junge menschen
sehr sehr stark eine kleine party ist
keine diskotheken keine keine klubs mehr
kann man auf dauer und auf dauer heißt
jetzt was weil sie auf ein jahr oder
zwei oder gar drei von von jungen leuten
die selber gar nicht gefährdet sind oder
in viel geringerem maße gefährdet sind
verlangen dass sie ihr leben
einschränken oder aufgeben
zugunsten der alten und gefährdet das
ist eine ganz schwere frage die ich gar
nicht theoretisch beantworten möchte
sondern ich glaube rein praktisch wir
werden das nicht tun
also ich glaube wir werden das
sukzessive irgendwann wieder zu lassen
selbst wenn die infektionszahlen auf dem
niveau bleiben wie sie gegenwärtig sind
ich glaube einfach dass man das nicht
machen wird dass man das so dauerhaft
jetzt untersagt weil die politik muss ja
zwei dinge berücksichtigen auf der einen
seite muss sie sehen dass sie keinen
großen fehler macht und die nötige
sicherheit gewährleistet und da ist man
im zweifelsfall lieber übervorsichtig
als allzu freizügig aus angst das wird
ein persönlich nachher angekreidet
ich werde unser gesundheitsminister hat
man große ambitionen da möchte er nicht
nur gesundheitsminister bleiben wenn der
jetzt also tatsächlich auf die idee
kommen würde zu voreilig ja von den
lockerungen abstand zu nehmen
dann wäre das sehr viel gefährlicher als
für seine karriere einst werde lieber
vorsichtig ist war und bei den maßnahmen
bleibt aber ich glaube dass der unmut in
der bevölkerung zwar jetzt nicht nur bei
der im kleinen prozentsatz von menschen
die nichts begriffen haben im hinblick
auf corona sondern auch bei denen die
bisher sehr folgsam waren dieser um gut
könnte stark steigen und das muss die
politik berücksichtigen
aber ich glaube dass die leute die den
richtigen riecher hatten am anfang wie
visa oder wie merkel auch den richtigen
riecher haben werden das traue ich ihm
zu zu erkennen wann sie lockern müssen
um die menschen nicht zu stark gegen
sich aufzubringen
richter jetzt mal den blick ein bisschen
mehr auf dauerhafte veränderung ich
würde zunächst einmal das
zwischenmenschliche interessieren was
bedeutet das denn wenn wenn der umarmung
der andere mensch plötzlich zur gefahr
wird ja ich persönlich habe das nie so
empfunden
ich habe diese diese angst nicht
körperlich oder nicht unmittelbar
gespürt deswegen weiß ich das nicht was
es für andere menschen bedeutet aber ich
hatte ja vorhin gesagt also entweder wir
finden einen impfstoff oder wir werden
uns in corona gewinnen und dann werden
die umarmungen sehr langsam aber
irgendwann auch wieder kommen
sie sagen sie selber haben sich jetzt
nicht so bedroht gefühlt aber viele
menschen fühlen sich sehr stark bedroht
manche menschen haben sich ja sehr stark
selber isoliert verändert dass die art
und weise wie wir leben und denken wenn
wenn ich mich da ständig bedroht an leib
und leben bedroht fühle
ja wenn das so wäre ist das
wahrscheinlich so aber ich kann die
frage nicht beantworten weil ich in
meinem gesamten umfeld niemand kenne bei
denen das so ist
es gibt ja menschen die die die g nicht
mehr zum einkaufen es gibt menschen die
aber wie viel prozent sind das also ich
glaube dass das eine verschwindend
kleine gruppe ist also mir persönlich
ist noch nie jemand begegnet und ich
kenne in meinem gesamten familien und
bekanntenkreis niemand der sagt ich
glaube mich zu hause ein weil ich so
viel angst haben also die restaurants
haben viele menschen gehen den
restaurants viele menschen benutzen
keine u-bahn mehr als ja nicht so dass
leute sich nicht nicht ihr verhalten
nicht drastisch geändert hätten
wahrscheinlich weil sie sich bedroht
fühlen ja also ich halte das durchaus
für möglich
aber ich kann nicht über den
bewusstseinszustand von menschen die ich
nicht kenne kann ich nicht urteilen und
nicht den richter spielen oder den
beruht anders
viele menschen sagen ja in jeder krise
liegt eine chance stimmt dieser satz
oder ist das einfach blödsinn
grundsätzlich ist erstmal eine floskel
also eine ziemlich banale floskel aber
wie das so oft ist viele floskeln gibt
es ja deswegen weil ja manchmal auch ein
bisschen wahrheit drin stecken kann
tatsächlich könnte man die these
aufstellen dass gesellschaften nur aus
krisen lernen was aber nicht im
umgekehrten schluss heißt dass aus jeder
krise die richtigen schlussfolgerungen
gezogen werden
solange business as usual ist verändern
gesellschaft sich nicht groß sie
verändert sich durch crash sie fangen an
sich durch krisen und deswegen könnte
man sagen potenziell gibt es immer einen
fonds zu größeren veränderungen den
krisenzeiten da sind als wenn ruhezeiten
sind das heißt welche chance könnte denn
jetzt in dieser krise liegen also welche
lehren könnte man aus dieser krise
ziehen ja wäre liebmann wurde daraus die
krise ziehen dass wir obwohl wir ja
hinzunehmen technischen welten leben
einen technischen welten leben anhand
des virus doch mal gemerkt haben dass
die größte bedrohung vor der wir stehen
nicht computerviren sind ja was wir
bisher immer geglaubt hatten hat man
angst vor dem absturz der börse durch
computerviren sondern das ist real
existierender tieren sind beim menschen
eben nach wie vor auch im
einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert leibliche
wesen sind biologische wesen sind und
durch biologische faktoren massiv
bedroht sind und die größte biologische
bedrohung die wir haben ist der
klimawandel
kronauer ist eine ganz kleine in
relation zum klimawandel weil corona
vermutlich irgendwann wieder weg ja und
der klimawandel der geht nicht mehr weg
naja wenn bestimmte kippelemente da sind
wenn die meeresströmung sich verändern
wenn der meeresspiegel steigt und so
weiter dann ist nichts mehr wie es
vorher war da gilt dieser satz der bei
corona seiner haft oft gesagt worden ist
nach der krise wird nichts mehr sein wie
es vorher war total im matsch aber beim
klimawandel gilt das wirklich machen wir
doch an der stelle in kleinen ausflug
was bedeutet das denn dass durch diese
corona krise alle anderen themen
zumindest in der öffentlichkeit beiseite
gedrängt wurden also man hat ja den
eindruck klimawandel migration
kinderarmut existiert alles überhaupt
nicht mehr
das ist den leuten irgendwie nicht so
richtig ins bewusstsein gekommen dass in
einem halben jahr wo wir jetzt mit
corona leben weltweit deutlich weniger
menschen an corona oder mit corona
gestorben sind als an hunger also die
real existierenden probleme in dieser
welt wenn wir die in einem ranking
bringen würden eine hierarchie dann
stünde corona sicher nicht nummer eins
aber für viele menschen steht corona
nummer eins weil sie sich unmittelbaren
mit corona konfrontiert sehen oder
bedroht sehen und das was sich
unmittelbar nach horizont fühle
das hat für die allermeisten menschen
weitaus größere bedeutung als das
bewusste ja wie zb die die hungernden
menschen oder der klimawandel
umweltzerstörung und so weiter die man
aber nicht tagtäglich erfährt will ich
noch mal ist es also jetzt richtig dass
wir uns mit dieser unmittelbaren
bedrohungen auseinandersetzen weil wenn
ich nicht aufpasse kriege ich diese
krankheit und zwar häufig so dass
zunächst einmal ist es richtig dass wir
uns sechs monate lang nur um dieses
thema bewegt haben aber natürlich hätten
wir alle anderen sieben sind natürlich
nicht unwichtiger geworden aber es ist
ja völlig verständlich dass corona eine
solche bedeutung für unsere gesellschaft
gekriegt hat sowohl in die medien wie in
gesprächen die die menschen miteinander
führen wie für die politik käme wieder
zu dauerhaften veränderungen durch die
korona krise zurück man hat ja den
eindruck dass sich gewisse prioritäten
verschoben haben also familie freunde
die eigene wohnung wird wichtiger kann
man ablesen möbelhäuser haben buben noch
nie soviel einbauküchen verkauft wurden
moment gerade also gibt es diese
verschiebung wir sein dieser kleine
kreis wird wichtiger und ist das auf
dauer
ich glaube dich dass es auf dauer ist
also ich glaube in dem moment wo die
freizeitangebote wieder zur verfügung
stehen übrigens um seine einbauküche in
aller ruhe selber einbauen zu können
da braucht man auch eine menge zeit ja
das eine gute voraussetzung dafür dass
wenn man auf kurzarbeit ist oder ähnlich
ist also sehr viele menschen sind hier
zu hause oder home office hatte
das war überhaupt die zeit hat dinge die
man ewig verschoben hat oder nicht
gemacht hat mal zu machen das wird jetzt
nicht auf dauer so weitergehen sondern
eben dem punkt glaube ich werden wir
irgendwann zum alten wieder zurückkehren
konsumverzicht es ist ja macht die so
richtig viel spaß einkaufen zu gehen
wenn man da immer eine maske tragen was
deswegen wird im moment einfach weniger
eingekauft man könnte ja annehmen okay
die leute gewöhnen sich daran ich brauch
vieles von dem was ich vorher gekauft
habe brauche ich vielleicht gar nicht
das könnte das von dauer sein das könnte
vielleicht etwas nachhaltiger sein als
das andere aber sicherlich nicht bei
vielen menschen aber bei einigen
menschen könnte das tatsächlich der fall
sein das halte ich für denkbar
das wäre natürlich jetzt ganz ganz
schlecht unter dem gesichtspunkt
wirtschaftswachstum ja wieder wieder auf
gute prozentzahlen und so weiter zu
kommen konnte konsumverzicht ist etwas
was sich unsere wirtschaft nicht leisten
kann und was wir dich aus
psychologischen gründen brauchen dann
haben wir eine viel zu viel zeug da
brauchen eigentlich mehr zeit und nicht
so viel zeug was ja aber aus
ökonomischen gründen sowie unser system
gegenwärtig funktioniert uns nicht
leisten können und ist für sie da diese
bedrohung unseres wirtschaftssystems
durch konsumverzicht eine chance weil
das helfen würde den kapitalismus zu
überwinden oder ist das eher eine
bedrohung weil arbeitsplätze sind
arbeitsplätze wegfallen die den
kapitalismus überwinden ist eigentlich
eine komische formel weil wenn man das
wollte müsste man eine verdammt gute
andere idee haben was besser
funktioniert und ich kenne niemanden der
so eine idee hat es geht eigentlich
nicht darum den kapitalismus zu
überwinden sondern es geht darum den
kapitalismus aus bestimmten
gesetzmäßigkeiten zu befreien der
kapitalismus sei zur zeit der
industriellen revolution als wendigen
kinder in den bergwerken verheizt hat
anders aus als die soziale
marktwirtschaft heute und was wir jetzt
brauchen
nun ist die transformation des
kapitalismus zu einer nachhaltigen
marktwirtschaft das ist sozusagen die
große agenda des einundzwanzigsten
jahrhunderts vor der wir stehen
und in dieser agenda müsste es möglich
sein ohne pausenlose steigerung von
konsum
gleichwohl das wirtschaftssystem am
leben zu erhalten das ist quasi die
große aufgabe vor der wir stehen
und das größte problem auf diesem weg
ist die bedrohung der politik durch
arbeitslosigkeit
also wenn wir tatsächlich konsumverzicht
machen würden und sagen wir müssen ja
gar nicht mehr so viel fliegen und wir
brauchen keine billig kreuzfahrten mehr
und ist auch kein suv fahren und so
weiter dann wäre die unmittelbare folge
davon arbeitslosigkeit und jeder
politiker jeder partei ist durch nichts
so sehr zu bedrohen als durch
ansteigende arbeitslosenzahlen und damit
legt sich das system bei dem versuch an
der transformation zur nachhaltigen
marktwirtschaft gegenwärtig sehen sie
denn diese tendenz auf dauer dass die
leute durch lernprozesse in dieser krise
vielleicht verzichten auf kreuzfahrten
urlaubsflüge kurzstreckenflüge suvs oder
kennen wir da auch wieder zum zustand
von vor zu lassen ist eine frage was der
staat macht also dann könnte ja rein
theoretisch sagen ein billig
kreuzfahrten wollen wir nicht mehr
oder wir können sagen luftverkehr unter
500 kilometern wollen wir nicht mehr
also wenn wir das machen dann setzten
sich die frage für die mittel schon gar
nicht mehr stellen
ich meine der wir werden diese die linke
in eine gesellschaft haben indem der
staat mir vorschreibt ich darf kein suv
fahren ich darf keine kreuzfahrt
verbieten den suv zu fahren der staat
kann sagen autos die über eine bestimmte
hubraumgröße verfügen dürfen nicht mehr
in städten fahren da sagt ja auch
verteilt ja auch umweltplaketten der
sagt ja auch mit dem und dem auto können
sie da und da nicht fahren das ist das
normalste von der welt dass wäre
überhaupt kein unterschied der stadt
verbietet nicht das suv der stadt
verbietet ihm mit dem suv innenstadt von
berlin zu fahren und die frage ist wenn
sie daneben ob ihnen dann ist wie fahren
noch spaß macht jetzt haben wir ja viel
gesprochen über die chancen die in
dieser krise liegen könnten
das ist uns noch mal über die risiken
sprechen
wie groß ist denn die gefahr dass der
staat nicht all die freiheitsrechte die
er aus guten gründen in dieser krise
genommen hat am ende auch wieder
zurückgibt
ich wüsste keinen einzigen grund warum
man das nicht machen sollte ja ich
versuche dich orban hätte ich die ihnen
angst und polen hätte ich diese angst
auch da würde ich sagen da gibt es genug
politiker die situation ausnutzen um
sich diktatorische vollmachten
anzueignen
ich sehe in deutschland keinen
bedeutenden politiker der irgendeine
grössere regierungsverantwortung trägt
der solche gelöst werden
hmm naja es gibt ja wenn man es mal im
kleinen es gibt eine ganze menge leute
die sagen dieses alkohol trinken und
partys auf großen plätzen in den städten
das hat mich schon gestört jetzt hat man
gerade einen guten grund gefunden das zu
verbieten ich glaube es gibt eine ganze
menge leute die sagen das könnte auf
dauer bleiben aber das wäre dann eher
auf kommunaler ebene
das wäre dann nicht oben der staat auf
der bundesebene das wäre so der
bürgermeister der sich sicher sein kann
dass ein großer teil der wähler ihn auch
weiter wählt wenn er bestimmte dinge
unterbindet oder in zukunft nicht mehr
zulässt und das halte ich für möglich
die krise wird ja an wie ein
brandbeschleuniger bei ganz vielen
tendenzen die sowieso gibt
digitalisierung zum beispiel da stecken
ja auch chancen und risiken drin wie
sehen sie das
ja also ein bisschen über drei feldern
also die ihr bei betrachten das eine ist
wenn mehr leute home office machen
statt mit mit ihrem wagen zur arbeit zu
fahren ist das unter ökologischen
gesichtspunkten
das wird natürlich nicht in dem umfang
erhalten bleiben die wir jetzt haben
aber ich glaube das home office hat von
kronau profitiert es ist deutlich
stärker akzeptiert ebenfalls stärker
akzeptiert sind videokonferenzen
na also der manager muss nicht immer
überall hinfliegen sondern die video
konferenz ist in der korona zeit für
viele fälle zur echten alternative
geworden das ist ein wunderbares tennis
finde ich großartig
das zweite was wir machen ist ja glauben
wir müssen unsere schulen radikaler
schneller digitalisieren
was mich daran stört es nicht dass wir
digitalisierung in der schule haben auch
nicht das schnellere netze in der schule
gibt oder dass das lern software gibt
was mich daran stört ist das das größte
problem unserer schulen nicht der mangel
an digitalisierung ist sondern einen
neuen lernkonzepten also wir lernen in
vielen dingen noch organisiert wie im
neunzehnten jahrhundert so wie wir
unsere schulstunden und unsere
klassenverbände haben und so das hat
alles nicht mehr viel mit lernen im
einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert zu tun und
ich hätte mir jetzt gewünscht dass man
die neuen digitalen möglichkeiten mit
neuen konzepten von lernen verbinden das
wäre sinnvoll gewesen aber ich kann
überhaupt nicht erkennen dass das
gegenwärtig irgendwo der fall ist das
dritte wäre die korona ebwo man sagen
muss das haben wir hat man in
deutschland die asyl gehandhabt das
haben wir ziemlich gut gemacht aber
dahinter steht natürlich trotz allem
eine gewisse illusion nämlich zu glauben
dass man auf rein technischem wege ein
virus besiegen kann das jetzt kein
technisches virus ist und da muss man
sagen dass die korona app kann immer nur
ein hilfsmittel sein aber es ist nicht
die lösung für eine infektion scri sie
an einer stelle ist ja die digitale
veränderung durch diese krise ganz
offensichtlich geworden nämlich beim
online-shopping der große sieger in
dieser pandemie ist amazon und die
verlierer stehen fest das ist vielleicht
karstadt kaufhof aber es sind vor allem
die kleinen geschäfte
das ist ja unter umständen nie mehr
zurück zu drücken ja ja das ist eine
große große katastrophe ich habe hier
vor einem jahr gesessen und habe auf
dieses problem schon vor corinna
aufmerksam gemacht das problem ist nicht
neu das gibt es seit einigen jahren dass
der online-handel den qualifizierten
einzelhandel bedroht das hat sich durch
die korona krise radikalisiert und sehr
interessant ist zu sehen dass von seiten
der bundesregierung keine einzige idee
bisher aufgekommen ist an diesem zustand
etwas zu ändern und man darf ja nicht
vergessen das geht ja nicht um folklore
also nicht um den bäckerladen dem man
immer schon gut fanden und in den
kleinen einzelhändler der da gearbeitet
hat sondern es geht darum dass es
irgendwann kein grund mehr gibt in die
städte zu gehen mal außerhalb der der
glitzermetropole nja die mit ihrem ganz
besonders hippen vierteln irgendetwas
anzubieten haben gibt es dann keinen
grund mehr eine innenstadt von essen zu
gehen oder von oberhausen oder von
rostock oder von solingen
und wenn die leute sich nicht mehr
treffen und miteinander jetzt nicht mehr
in kontakt sind dann schwindet quasi die
öffentlichkeit dahin und das ist von
großem schaden für unsere politische
kultur und ich hätte mir gewünscht dass
man die online gigant mit einer extra
wer werk steuer belegt und dieses geld
dem qualifizierten einzelhandel zur
verfügung zu stellen
ja dass wir also diversität förderung
machen aber ich habe von keinem einzigen
politiker in der gesamten corona zeit
irgendetwas in diese richtung gehört
es hat sich ja so ein bisschen wie ein
roter faden durch dieses gespräch
durchgezogen dass sie sehr skeptisch
sind und gar nicht glauben dass diese
corona krise so sehr viel verändern wird
liegt das unter umständen auch daran
dass die menschen in dieser krise
erkennen
mein altes leben war gar nicht so
schlecht
das ist eigentlich also mich mal keiner
aber nur von den menschen sprechen die
man kennt und da würde ich nicht sagen
dass alle sagen ich möchte jetzt
schnellstmöglich zu meinem alten leben
zurück sondern das was ich vorhin
beschrieben habe diese diese zeit des
weniger und diese zeit in der man mehr
zeit hatte die haben glaube ich viele
menschen auch als positiv empfunden
und ich glaube auch dass das nachhaltig
wirkt und ich wenn man daran anknüpfen
würde dann wäre das gar keine schlechte
voraussetzung um sich zu überlegen was
von ihrem alten war so toll dass wir es
genau wieder haben wollen und wo müssen
wir tatsächlich die dinge verändern um
eine lebenswerte zukunft zu haben
das war völlig persönlich heute mit
richard david precht herzlichen dank
gerne